전 과산물을 좋아해요.
네, 새우깡, 자갈칩.
농심 계열이네요.
극종은 또 이 농심이..
아니, 꼬깔칩도 좋아해요, 저는.
꼬깔칩이라고 하셨어요?
두쫑쿠 열풍은 좀 언제가 고점일 거라고 보세요?
저희가 지금 얘기하고 있는 게 고점입니다.
아니, 그럼 김이 이렇게 글로벌에서 잘 팔리면
스냅뉴의 엔비디아는 약간 과자 기업이 아니라
이런 양반, 김만드는 회사에서 나올 수도 있지 않을까요?
그건 좀 고민스러운 게..
소비문화위원회 경제 이야기, 비주류 경제학 호스트를 맡은
저는 토스 김창선이고요.
저는 재무덕후 이재용입니다.
이번 주 비주류 경제학 주제는 과자인데요.
게스트로 정동현 팀장님 모셨습니다.
어서 오세요.
반갑습니다.
아, 팀장님 또 오셨습니다.
아, 그러니까요.
비주류 경제학 벌써 세 번째 출연이신데
그간에 좀 어떻게 지내셨는지 근황이 궁금해요.
아..
뭔가 이렇게 깊은 데서 나오는데, 한숨이?
작년에 많은 일이 있었다.
네, 뭐..
많은 일이 있었다.
저희 백화점에 있는 푸드 시설들?
그러니까 식품관의 리뉴얼?
이런 것들 기획하고, 컨텐츠 개발하고, 이런 것들 하고 있죠.
점점 핵심 부서 아니에요?
그 푸드라는 게 이 백화점 채널에서..
제일 중요하시지 않아요, 요새?
그거 먹으러 가는 거잖아요, 원래 백화점에.
그렇게 시장이 얘기한 지가 이제 10년..
최상의 중심은 푸드다.
네, 그러니까.
그런 얘기만 하고 있죠.
아니, 근데 이제 백화점에서 그중에서도 푸드 분야면
우리나라 어떤 F&B 트렌드나 이런 것들도
제일 앞에서 좀 지켜보실 것 같은데
좀 요즘 F&B 트렌드.
어떤 결정입니까?
재밌는 거는 두쫑쿠 같아요.
여전히 두쫑쿠.
아직도 두쫑쿠.
아직은 두쫑쿠인데
저는 초콜릿류가 계속 잘 될 거라고 생각하는 사람입니다.
그러니까 두바이 초콜릿이든 두쫑쿠든
핵심은 초콜릿이에요.
그리고 두쫑쿠가 연 어떤 마켓은
나를 위해서 만 원짜리 알을, 작은 거를
살 수 있는 시장이 열렸다고 생각이 들어요.
나만 먹는 그런 디저트 한 알에
만 원까지 쓸 수 있는 어떤 시대가 지금 열렸다.
그전까지는 한국 사람이 1년에 초콜릿 얼마나 먹어?
500g밖에 안 먹어.
이런 식으로 이제 한국 사람 초콜릿 안 먹어라는
비관적인 뷰가 한 20년.
그래서 막 왔다 철수하고 왔다 철수하고 하고 있는데
현재 이제 글로벌 초콜릿 플레이어라고 하죠.
네종도 초콜라든 아니면 알링디카스든
비싼 초콜릿을 파는 사람들이 다시 진출을 하고 있어요.
그런 마켓도 있고 두쫑쿠나 두바이도 있고 하다 보면
다양한 초콜릿 상품들이 계속 반복적으로 유행하게
되지 않을까 하는 생각을 하고 있어요.
두쫑쿠 다음도 결국에 핵심은 초콜릿에서 시작할 거다.
그러면 두쫑쿠 열풍은 좀 언제가 고점일 거라고 보세요?
이 방송 나가는 3월에도 고점일 것 같은데
저희가 지금 얘기하고 있는 게 고점입니다.
내일부터 끝나요.
오늘로써 종료.
지금 당장.
지금이 고점이다.
이렇게 탕후루, 두쫑쿠, 요아전 같은
핫한 디저트들은 계속 생겨나는데
오늘 주제인 과자는 한동안 대란템이 좀 없었던 것 같아요.
과자는 왜 요새 대란템인가요?
대란템이 많이 사라지고 있다고 생각을 하세요.
허니버터칩에 아직 잔 향이 10년 넘게 남아있는 것 같아요.
그게 고점이었던 것 같아요.
그 정도 난리치지 않으면 히트 안 한 거네요.
그렇지.
그 정도는 줄 서서 먹어야 된다.
메론킥도 사실 엄청 먹고 있잖아요.
먹태깡도 없어서 못 팔던 시절이 있어요.
저는 메론킥이 히트한 줄 몰랐는데
주변에 물어보면 다 메론킥이 지금 제일 핫하다고 얘기하는 것 같아요.
이미 다 먹고 있죠.
저만 또 안 먹었나 봐요.
메론킥 안 먹었어요?
안 먹었어요.
먹태깡은 먹었어요?
먹태깡도 안 먹었어요.
아.
근데
뭐 과자를 잘 안 먹는 편이긴 한데
아무것도 안 먹는 편인데 그게.
아니 먹태깡은 그렇게.
과자가 아니라 아무것도 안 먹는 편.
그럼 일단 트렌드는 좀 제쳐두고
두 분의 최애 과자가 뭔지 궁금해요.
일단 팀장님의 최애 과자는 뭔가요?
전 해산물을 좋아해서.
해산물?
새우깡, 자갈치.
농심 계열이네요.
그쪽은 또
아니, 꽈깔칩도 좋아요.
제가.
꽈깔칩이라고 하셨어요.
뒤늦게 꽈깔칩 하나 끼워넣었어요.
아니야, 꽈깔칩 아니야.
꽈깔콘이야.
꽈깔콘.
어떡해.
그러면 재용 님은 어떤 게 좀 최애 과자예요?
저는 무조건 새우깡이고요.
무조건 새우깡?
무조건 새우깡.
마트 가면 일반 새우깡, 쌀새우깡, 매운새우깡 다 집어옵니다.
오.
그렇게 해서 매운맛, 짠맛을 보충하고
그러다 좀 단맛이 좀 땡기면
이제 조청유가.
아.
바삭한 거 먹고 싶다, 꽈깔칩.
이 정도는 거의 이제
마트 가면 기본적으로 집어오는 시리즈 중에 하나인 것 같아요.
아니, 저는 뭐 과자에 대한 기호가 엄청 크지 않으니까.
근데 두 분 다 새우깡을 어쨌든
1번이라고 뽑아주셨잖아요.
새우깡이 두 분한테 1번인 이유가 뭐예요?
왜 그럴까요?
새우깡은 정말
그 짭짤한 맛과 새우의 풍미라는 게
대단하다.
그러니까 그 농심이 좀 재밌는 게
새우깡, 자갈치 뭐 이런 애들이야.
감자깡이나 뭐 이런.
그러니까 이게 라면에서의 유탄기술 있죠.
라면에서 유탄기술로 다 과자를 튀기는 거고
그 라면에서 배운 그런 건조 분말들 있잖아요.
스프.
이런 것들이 사실
또 과자 쪽으로 연결이 되는 거죠.
라면의 기술이 접목된 거군요.
새우깡은 마스터피스예요.
더 이상의 과자는 인류에게 나올 수가 없는 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 다 아시겠지만 농심 과자는 전반적으로
우리가 생각하는 일반적인 간식에 비해 농도가 조금 낮습니다.
짠가 싶으면 좀 덜 짜.
단가시면 좀 덜 달아.
왜냐하면 손이 가요, 손이 가야 되거든요.
너무 짜거나 너무 달면 손이 안 가요.
한 번 먹고.
근데 이게 또 애매하게 생각나게 만드는
그 적절한 농도를 정말 잘 지키는 거고
그거의 끝판왕이 새우깡 아닌가.
그러니까 스낵이란 것들은 습관이잖아요.
내가 탐험을 하는 과정이 아니라
내가 저녁이 됐을 때 그 순간 불이 하나 꺼지고
애들이 자고 아무도 없을 때
그럼 되면 이제 회로가 도는 거예요.
이때는 새우깡이지.
습관처럼.
내 입에 박혀 있는 맛.
저도 자료를 보다 보니까
맛동산.
맛동산의 탄생 시점이 1974년.
에이스 1976년.
이런 식이에요, 거의.
1970년대에는 도대체 무슨 일이 있었을까요?
그때 뭐 애를 많이 낳던 시절이어서
스낵류가 되게 잘 되던 시절이었던 거예요.
영양분이 부족했던 시절.
그러고 보면 우리 과자들이 좀 절대적으로 맛있다라기보다는
살아오면서 먹었던 우리 두뇌의 입맛에 각인된 것이 때문에
잘 나가는 거 아닌가 하는 생각도 들기도 하네요.
맞아요.
이번엔 과자에 대한 재용 님의 이야기가 좀 궁금한데
과자에서 이렇게 재무감사 이런 거 해보시면서
기업에서 좀 느껴졌던 특이한 어떤 분위기나.
문화 같은 것도 있어요?
일단 과자 회사 같은 경우는 100원을 굉장히 아쉬워하죠.
아, 100원.
맞다.
100원대기입니다.
100원대기?
10원대기죠.
10원대기?
그러니까 기업 문화 자체가
저 과자 하나를 라인업으로 깔 때
새로운, 예를 들어서 그냥 맛만 교체한다.
그러니까 가루 시즈닝만 교체한다고 하면
최소한 몇 천만 원에서 몇 억 정도?
그냥 약간 배합기 정도만 세팅하면 되는데
이게 만약에 새로운 어떤 폼팩터를 만든다.
모양 자체가 달라.
모양이 나온다.
그러면 수십억, 크면 수백억까지 들어가야 되는데
몇 천만 봉 팔려야 이게 좀 손익 계산이 나오거든요.
그러다 보니까 작게 작게 계속 시즈닝만 바꿔가면서
포장지만 바꿔먹으면서 시도를 하는 과자 회사들의 사정이 좀 있죠.
팀장님도 좀 비슷한 의견이신가요?
그러니까 뭐 꼬북칩도 한 8년간 100억을 들였다, 개발비만.
8년 동안 만들었어요?
네, 그 짧은 4겹을 만들기 위해서 100억을 들였다.
그런 얘기가 있을 정도로 사실은
오랜 시간이 걸렸어요.
제가 사실은 신입사원 때 처음 했던 게 대형마트에서 과자를 담당했어요.
매대요?
매대, 매대.
과자랑 라면을 제가 관리했었는데
그 당시에 2008년 정도니까 오리온, 롯데, 혜태, 크라운, 청우.
영업사들이 막 오고 아까 말씀하셨던 것처럼 옆에서 뭐 하는지.
그러면 계속 똑같은 거 나와.
하나가 나오면 바로 나와.
뭐 롯데에서 자일리티를 만들면 오리온도 꽃 만들고.
네.
그런 종류의 혁신은 안 하지만 해외 진출에 대한 어떤 과감성?
그런 것들은 또 보다 보니까 이 업계는 좀 다른 종류의 어쨌든 도전을 많이 하고 있구나.
시장을 뚫는 도전을 많이 하고 있구나.
그러니까 제조공장을 해외에 세운다는 거는 쉽지는 않거든요.
인도, 베트남, 러시아에 공장을 세우고 있어요.
잘 나가죠, 오리온.
오리온도 잘 나가고.
러시아 외출이 늘고 있어요.
아, 그래요?
작년 대비 45%, 48%가 그만큼 오른 거예요.
보드카이 초콜릿.
초코파이.
네, 먹어줘야죠.
그런데 또 다시 포카칩 얘기를 잠깐 해보면 포카칩이 대략 1년에 쓰는 감자가 24만 톤?
한국에서 생산되는 감자가 54만 톤 정도 돼요.
네, 한국에서만 사지는 않아요.
한국에서만 사지는 않아요.
네몽골에는 직영 농장이 있어요.
다른 데서는 또 계약 재배를 하고.
그러니까 세계적으로 이 감자를 유통하고 개발하고.
맞아요.
그러니까 이런 일을 하고 있는 거예요.
그러니까 그런 면에서 사업에 진출의 영역 단위는 상당히
공격적이라는 생각이 들었어요.
맞아요.
그러니까 이 보수적인 시장에서의 어떤 확고한 그런 자리나 이런 걸 차지하기 위해서
뒤에서는 엄청난 그런 진출이라든지 유통이라든지 이런 부분에서 노력을 하고 있는.
비주류 경제와 과자 편 본격적인 이야기를 시작해 볼 텐데요.
가격에 예민한 공산품이기도 하지만
제2의 면비비아를 꿈꿔볼 수 있는 그런 산업이 아닐까 싶기도 해요.
일단 업계에서는 과자를 크게 생 스낵이랑 재가로 나눈다고 들었는데
이 두 개가 좀 어떤 차이가 있는 건가요?
스낵은 저희가 생각하는 어쨌든.
바삭바삭한 이런 과자류 보통 튀김 유탕튀김 이런 것들을 얘기를 하는 거고.
짠맛 나는 거예요 스낵이라고.
짠맛이.
단맛도 나죠.
단맛도 나죠 요즘에는.
보통 봉지에 들어 있으면 스낵.
질소 충전한.
질소와 같이 있는.
이런 애들을 스낵이라고 하고 재가는 어쨌든 오븐에서 굽는 그런 유들.
그러니까 비스킷이라든가 쿠쿠다스 같은 애들.
그런 애들을 보통 저희가 재가라고 보통 얘기를 하는데.
그럼 공장 설비나 이런 것들도 완전히 다르게 하겠네요.
스낵용 공장이 있고 재가용 공장이 있고.
다를 수밖에 없죠.
스낵 같은 경우에는 아까 말씀하셨던 것처럼 파우더라든가.
텀블러 공법이라고 하죠.
이렇게 막 통해서 섞어가지고.
푸셔푸셔처럼 이렇게 섞어서 하는 것들도 있고.
슬러리라고 해서 액을 짜가지고.
붙여가지고 배터리 공정처럼 이렇게 묻혀가지고.
찐득찐득하게 만드는 애들 있잖아요.
닭다리 이런 애들.
그렇게 공법이 좀 달라지긴 하고요.
그러면 이제 회사 중에서도 스낵을 잘하는 회사 있고 재가를 잘하는 회사.
이런 회사들도 나뉘어지기도 하나요?
엄연히 나뉘어져 있죠.
선명하죠.
롯데는 선명하죠.
롯데는 그래도 재가 빈과 이쪽 껌 초콜릿 특히 작은 애들을 잘하죠.
잘 있을 껌 거의 90% 점유율 있고.
그다음에 가나 초콜릿 독보적인 위치를 가지고 있지 않습니까?
롯데가 초콜릿률이 그렇게 잘하는 이유는 뭐예요?
이게 1974년 이때 75년이었나요?
그때 가나 초콜릿이 처음 한국에서는 시작을 했었는데.
현재도 마찬가지지만 카카오 원두를 수입해서 빈 투 바라고 하죠.
빈을 그대로 수입을 해가지고.
가공해서 하는 공장은 한국에 롯데밖에 없어요.
그런 설비 자체를 갖춘 회사가 롯데밖에 없어요.
그러니까 경쟁이 들어올 수가 없네요.
초콜릿 계열은 롯데가 꽉 잡고 있어요.
왜냐면 그렇게 최적화를 해놨고 인지도는 높고.
그런데 있으니까 굳이 이걸 몇백억?
몇천억?
그래서 할 이유가 없고.
경쟁에 뛰어들 이유가 없죠.
재용님의 시선에서 우리 대표적인 과자회사들을 구분한다면 어떻게
구분을 해볼 수 있을까요?
제 시선에서 구분하면 아까 말씀드렸듯이.
농심 같은 경우는.
스낵계의 일장.
농심.
스낵은 특히 밀가루 베이스의 봉지 과자는 스낵이 제일 잘 만든다.
농심이 제일 잘 만든다.
왜냐면 라면에서 온 기술력이 있기 때문에.
그리고 감자를 제일 잘 만드는 건 오리온.
감자에선 오리온이다.
왜냐면 수많은 감자칩이 있지만 포카칩이 점유율 상으로는 압도적이거든요.
그런데 오리온은 또 올라운드 플레이어인 게 비스킷이나 이런 초코케익류도 잘해요.
그렇죠. 초코파이를 가지고 있잖아요.
초코파이 압도적인 초코파이라는 강력한 모델이죠.
그래서 오리온은 약간 올라운드 플레이어 같은 느낌이 좀 있고요.
롯데는 말씀하신 것처럼 초콜렛 플러스 꼬깔콘.
어쩌다 나온 건지 모르겠는데 꼬깔콘은 정말 맛있어요.
우리나라 옥수수 베이스의 과자 중에 저렇게 잘 된 과자가 있거든요.
그러니까 하필 또 옥수수 베이스.
세계 3대 작물. 밀가루, 쌀, 옥수수인데.
옥수수가 유달리 한국에서는 그렇게 잘 나가는 과자가 아닌데.
옥수수 베이스로 정말 잘 되는 거는 이제 꼬깔콘이 압도적인 것 같고요.
그리고 해테 같은 경우는.
달달한 거 잘 만드는 회사.
마똥산이나 홈런볼.
아 홈런볼.
산도나 뭐 이런 하임. 초코하임류.
그러니까 비스킷인데 달달한.
당을 잘 커야 하는 회사가 해테와 크라운이다.
쿠크다스 이런 것도.
그렇죠. 명작이죠. 명작이죠.
이런 게 좀 궁금한 게.
약간 각 브랜드마다 대표하는 그런 제품도 있고.
대표하는 카테고리가 있는 것 같고.
이런 효자 상품들이 나뉘는 게 우연인 건지.
아니면 약간.
뭔가 블루오션인지 찾아다니다가 각 위치를 좀 점하게 된 건지.
궁금하더라고요.
제가 볼 때는 일단 제일 먼저 시도를 했고.
먼저 시도를 하게 되면 아까 이제 롯데의 초콜렛처럼 수직 계열화가 되면서 최적화가 됩니다.
원가를 제일 낮게 만들 수가 있어요.
예를 들어서 오리온이 감자칩을 압도적으로 생산하다 보니까.
감자와 관련된 어떤 이 수직 계열화는 오리온이 굉장히 잘 돼 있습니다.
다른 회사 감자칩을 만들면 오리온만큼의 원가를 만들 수가 없습니다.
오리온이 만들어 놓은 그 구조와 원가율 같은 거에 함부로 침입하기가 어렵습니다.
네.
함부로 침입하기가 어렵군요.
그러니까 다른 플레이어들을 쉽게 도전할 수 없는 그런 상황이 되고.
그게 만약에 우리가 고도 성장하는 국가여서 인구 수 폭발적으로 늘어나고 소비 능력도 늘어나면.
내가 큰 돈을 투입해서라도 그걸 한번 도전해 보겠는데.
이제 5천만 명의 인구 수에서 고착하는 지 굉장히 오래된 국가이기 때문에.
도전할 시장 사이즈가 안 나옵니다.
그러니까 딱 그렇게 각자의 영역을 가르마를 타고.
저기 그냥 줘.
초콜렛은 롯데 줘.
서로 침범하기 어려운 각자의 어떤 영토에서 굉장히.
단단한 그런 좀 자기의 어떤 핵심 자산을 가지고 있는 거라고 보면 되겠네요.
그렇죠.
그럼 이쯤에서 우리나라에서 제일 잘 팔리는 스낵과 재과.
이런 거 순위표를 좀 저희가 볼 수 있나요?
네.
대략 에이티에서 내는 소매 매출 통계 자료를 5년치를 이제 꼽아 봤는데요.
일단 카테고리 측면에서 스낵을 제일 먼저 보면.
스낵에서 압도적인 1위는 언제나 새우깡.
아 역시 새우깡.
5년 동안 매출이 한 5,400억 정도 나니까 연에 한 1,000억씩은 팔려요.
요즘 2위가 스토어.
네.
스토어 브랜드라고 나오는데.
이게 뭐예요?
PV 상품.
아.
근데 이건 한 제품이 아니죠.
수십 가지 제품을 합쳐서.
CU, GS, 이마트에 있는 모든 PV를 다 합쳐서.
네.
얘네들이 이제 자꾸 순위가 올라가고 있어요.
물론 다 뭉쳐서 올라가는 거긴 한데 그만큼 편의점의 유통 채널의 힘이
점점 강해지고 있다는 말이기도 하고요.
뭐 그거 빼고 보면 포카칩이 2위죠.
네.
포카칩도 지금 5년 동안 한 4,500억 정도 찍히는 거 보니까 연에 한
900억 정도는 팔려나가고 있고.
네.
그다음이 꼬깔콘 3위.
프링글스.
약간 이런 식이고.
새우깡 포카칩이 확실히 탑 2네요.
탑 2예요.
여기는 10년 전에도 탑 2였고.
10년 전에도 그랬을 거 같은데요.
맞아요.
계속 안 바뀌어요.
이쪽은 애초에 바꿀 수 없는.
마치 신라면처럼.
네.
그렇죠.
이 순위에서 오징어 땅콩이 좀 저는 특이해 보여요.
왜요?
이거 약간 저는 좀 미치한 시장이라고 생각했거든요.
네.
왜냐하면 좀 비려하는 사람들이 있어.
드셔보는 거 보셨어요?
먹어봤죠.
이거는 내 나이대 먹는 음식은 아닌 거 같다.
라는 생각이 있었는데.
근데 오징어 땅콩이 만들기가 제일 어려운 과자 중의 하나예요.
그래 보이긴 해요.
긍정 난이도가 그 적절한 바삭함과 쫀득함을 만드는 게.
안에 들어있고 레이어가 이렇게 있잖아요.
아무도 못 따라해요.
그래서 그것도 오리온 거거든요.
그것도 아마 그 레시피를 아는 사람이 몇 명 없다고 해요.
회사에.
의외로 되게 고난이도.
고난이도의 제품이고.
반도체 같은 과자.
굉장히 이제 자기 영역에 확고한.
그렇죠.
팬들이 많아요.
그러면 스낵 말고 다른 카테고리의 리스트도 좀 궁금한데.
비스킷뉴 쪽으로는 제일 크게 보이는 게.
홈런볼.
저 홈런볼 좋아해요.
여기 5년 동안 4000억 찍히는 거 보니까 연예 한 800억 정도로 굉장히 효자 브랜드고.
그다음에 조금 차이가 나는 연예 5년 동안 2500 팔린 에이스.
커피 찍어 먹는.
에이스.
이거 롯데 거죠.
에이스는 혜택 겁니다.
죄송합니다.
에이스 혜택 거.
헷갈려.
그러니까.
에이스.
그다음에 반생 초코케이크라는 카테고리가 있어요.
초코케이크인데 딱딱하지 않고 말랑하지 않은.
약간.
중간 어딘가에 반생.
약간 빵 같은 개념이 섞여 있는 그런.
초코파이라고 얘기하면 돼요.
초코파이.
압도적인 초코파이.
초코파이계.
초코파이계로 초코파이 1위.
오이에스.
몽쉘.
이런 식으로 내려오지만 격차는 초코파이와 차이는 조금 많이 난다고 한다.
이 계열에서는 초코파이가 점유율이 32%네요.
그렇죠.
이 카테고리를 거의.
초코파이를 위한 카테고리라고 봐야겠죠.
이번에 기업별로 보면 좋을 것 같은데.
국내 과자회사들 성장하고 있는지 한번 볼까요.
국내 과자회사를 당연히.
당연히?
라고 하는 게 좀 웃기긴 한데.
잘 성장하고 있습니다.
매출이 감소한 회사는 단 하나도 없고요.
비교를 해보면 일단 스낵 쪽에서 제일 크게 큰 회사가 농심이고요.
농심이 2024년 기준 매출액이 3조4천억을 찍어요.
그런데 전년도에도 3조4천억.
이제 2022년 3조1천억으로 나름 이제 2022년부터 보면 성장하는 그림으로 가고 있고.
다만 이제 농심 같은 경우는 한 70% 정도가 라면 매출이기 때문에 그거는 좀 감안해서 봐야 되긴 하지만.
매출 원가율은 한 70%대에서 왔다 갔다.
그리고 영업이익은 한 5%에서 플러스 마이너스 왔다 갔다 하면서.
1,500억에서 2,000억 내외를 팔고 남기는 회사다라고 보시면 될 것 같고요.
롯데 같은 경우는 롯데 재과가 예전에는 독립기업이었는데 지금 웰푸드라는 회사로 합병이 돼서.
햄이나 빙과까지 포함한 전체 매출이라고 보셔야 되고.
전체 매출이 한 4조 원 중에 한 비스킷 초콜릿이 한 25% 즉 한 1조 원 정도를 우리가 알고 있는 과자류에서 나온다라고 보시면 될 것 같고.
영업이익률 한 3에서 4%대 정도로 왔다 갔다 하고 있어서.
약간 농심이랑 전체 사이즈는 비슷한 규모로 보시면 될 것 같아요.
오리온 같은 경우는 2024년 기준 매출액이 3조 1,000억입니다.
전년도에는 2조 9,000억, 전전년도에는 2조 8,000억으로 꾸준히 성장하는 기업이고요.
특이한 건 오리온은 전부 다 스낵 혹은 과자.
거의 순수하게 스낵으로만 이루어지는 매출.
농심은 아까 70%가 라면이라고 그랬는데.
재과 스낵만 팔아서 3조를 파는 아주 압도적인 규모를 잡았고요.
나랑하는 회사고요.
특이한 건 매출원가율이 낮아요.
61%.
그러니까요.
61, 62% 정도를 유지하면서 그러다 보니까 영업이익률이 17%.
딱 정확하게 10% 낮은 만큼 영업이익률이 10% 올라가는 거예요.
그게 왜 그러냐면 수출 매출이 국내 매출보다 커서 그래요.
여기서 수출 나가는 건 대부분 초코파이 같은 걸까요?
초코파이도 그렇고 요즘에 꼬북칩도 미국에서 되게 잘 나간다고 하고요.
꼬북칩이요?
중국 매출이 일단 한국 매출보다 많고.
중국에 진출한 지 오래돼서.
중국에서는 당연히 초코파이 포함해서 오리온 포트폴리오가 되게 좋기 때문에 다양하게 팔릴 수 있을 것 같고.
베트남, 러시아에서 3개국에서 나오는 매출액이 꽤 큽니다.
이게 오리온의 2014년에 이마트의 대표로 있던 허인철 부회장님이 이마트 이직을 했던 시기가 2014년이에요.
그 당시에 영업이익률이 대략 9%대가 나왔었거든요.
그러면서 그 이후에 이 영업이익률이.
사실 계속 올라가는 추세를 보였던 게 그 중반이에요.
반품이라든가 이런 밀어내기라든가 이런 것들이 2010년 그 이후에 되게 심해졌던 시대가 있었어요.
반품률이 오리온 같은 경우에도 3%까지 올라갔던.
일주일에 팔면 300억을 반품시키고.
그 당시에 한창 질소 충전 이슈도 있었고.
그 다음에 이때 사드도 있었고.
그러니까 여러모로 오리온이라든가 이런 회사에 영업이익률이 낮아질 수밖에 없는 많은 문제들이 있었죠.
그런데 현재는 그런 자잘자잘한 원가 절감이라든가 이런 것들을 해내가면서 됐는데
조사를 하다 보니 이 허인철 부회장이 가장 인상 깊었던 회사가 어디냐 하니 코스트코가 또 나오는 거예요.
코스트코요?
신세계 사람들이 보통 코스트코랑 많이 연결이 되는데 그 전에 코스트코에서 연수를 받았다는 거예요.
그러니까 그거를 계속 본인은 원가 절감해야 된다.
그 다음에 sku 줄여야 된다.
필요 없는 거 줄여야 된다.
환관비 줄여야 된다.
이런 것들에 대한 철학이 계속 발현이 되면서 한 10년간 그런 경영의 효율화된 결과가 17.5%라는 영업이익률이 나왔던 거고.
결국은 그래서 리가켄 바이오 그런 거 사고 있고 그런 거죠.
이것도 좀 궁금해요.
한국 사람들의 과자에 대한 입맛이랑 해외라고 해봤자 너무 다양하긴 하지만 해외 사람들의 과자에 대한 입맛의 차이가 좀 있나요?
사서 드셔보시면 있잖아요.
미국, 영국 이런 애들은 sour.
네.
신 맛 갑자기 나오고.
약간 콩깃콩 맛 나는 거.
전통 칩스에 식초 뿌리면 전통이 유구하게 이렇게 펼쳐지는 건데 sour하거나 아니면 되게 짜거나.
왜냐하면 걔네들은 콜라랑 어쨌든 많이 탄산음료랑 많이 먹다 보니까 그 단짠의 밸런스를 거기서 찾는 것 같아요.
단독으로 먹지 않는다.
제가 지난달에 스페인 갔다 왔잖아요.
네.
그 레이지 우리 감자칩 레이지에서 나오는 꼬깔콘이 있어요.
레이지에서 꼬깔콘이 나와요?
있어요. 똑같이 생겼어요.
그래서 제가 스페인 마트 가가지고.
어? 꼬깔콘이네? 하고 딱 집어서 한 입 딱 먹었거든요.
정확하게 모아서 버렸어요.
왜?
너무 짜.
이게 뭐야 아마.
레이지도 좀 짠 편이잖아요.
네. 네. 네.
아 외국인들의 입맛을 진짜 이해할 수가 없다.
그러니까 이게 콜라랑 맥주 같은 거랑 해서 계속 씻어내면서 먹었어야 되는.
우리 생각보다 훨씬 더 탄산음료를 많이 마시기 때문에.
네. 네. 네.
우리는 탄산을 먹을 때 죄책감을 느끼면서 먹지만 이미 이렇게 해서 먹기 때문에 그 배합이 다르다.
음.
반대로 우리나라에서 인기 있는 뭐 새우깡이나 오징어 땅콩 같은 거는 별로 인기 없겠네요 해외에서는.
맛이 좀 심심할 수 있겠죠.
어.
그 다음에 우리나라는 단짠을 그 안에서 그냥 해결해버리는 경우도 많고.
음.
사실 허니버터칩이 처음에 잘 됐던 것도 그 단짠에.
그러니까 이거를 스낵이 아니라 디저트 스낵으로.
어. 달달한 감자칩이라니. 이런.
밥을 먹고 후식으로 스낵을 먹고.
어.
이런 느낌스가 되어버리니까.
네.
사실 좀 맛의 스펙트럼이 다르다라고 볼 수 있죠.
음.
이것도 좀 궁금해요.
사실 저희가 얘기한 그런 한국 과자류는 아닌데.
음.
의외로 해외 사람들이 좋아하는 한국의 스낵이 김이라고 하더라고요.
아.
김을 좀 먹죠.
네.
그 팀장님도 체감을 하세요? 외국 사람들이 김을 좋아하는 것.
롯데마트에서 2025년에 그 해외 베스트 텐?
네.
이런 걸 들어가면 거기 김부각이 들어가 있어요.
음.
김부각.
하하하.
그냥 김도 아니고 부각 형태로.
음.
김부각.
김부각이 들어가 있어요.
음.
그래서 뭐 작년 매출이 전체 김 수출액이 1조 6천억인가?
네.
그 정도 됐다고 했을 정도로.
맞아요.
김의 시장은 엄청 커지고 있죠.
네.
그러니까 우리가 그렇게 생각 안 해봤지.
외국인의 관점에서 김을 보면 맛있는 과자나 스낵의 요소를 다 갖추고
있잖아요.
맞아요.
식감.
맛.
짠맛.
아니면 그런 해조류를 이렇게 튀겨서 먹는다는 그런 좀 특이한 요소들
까지 가지고 있어서.
맞아요.
김이 약간 새로운 다크호스가 될 것 같다?
그러니까 우리도 옛날에 생각해보면.
그렇죠.
밥 먹고 김이 이렇게 쌓여있는데.
네.
밥 다 먹고 그거 다 먹어본 적 있지 않아요?
어.
맞아요.
그리고 그렇게만 먹으면.
아.
밥은 다 먹었는데.
김 한 15장 쌓여있는데 그거 다 먹었어.
네.
그냥 guilty pleasure 같은 느낌.
그래서 김을 초콜릿에서 부쳐요.
음.
아.
그건 좀.
그렇게는.
그렇게는 싫은데요.
맞다니까.
그건 좀 싫은데요.
아니 그럼 김이 이렇게 글로벌에서 잘 팔리면 약간 미래에 어떤 면비디아
약간 스낵류의 엔비디아는.
음.
이런 양반.
네.
cj.
아니면 뭐 동원.
네.
아 그건 좀 고민스러운게 원물 생산이 그렇게 늘어날 수 있을까? 아 우리나라에서 재료를 수급해야.. 왜냐면 이거는 다른 예를 들어서 뭐
새우깡이 잘 팔린다 밀을 수입하면 되요 밀은 세계 2대 작물이니까 감자가 잘 팔린다
감자 수매를 더 많이 하면 되요 김은 원물 그 자체란 말이죠 가공이 아니라 뭘 섞는게 아니라 김 그 자체예요 그쵸 원물이 중요하죠
어 이거를 그렇게 많이 늘릴 수 있을까 라는 고민이 좀 들긴 하는데 근데 오히려 그렇게 하입이 붙으면 가격을 올릴 수도 있겠다
생산량을 막 늘릴 수 있는게 아니니까 현재 가격이 너무 싸죠 한국이 제일 싸요 삼국중에서
마트에서 이만큼 막 엄청 가득 포장되어 있는거 사도 그렇게 가격 부담이 안되더라구요 한중일 삼국 중에서 한국이 제일 싸요
중국이 아니라 그 정도로 김이 되게 저가고 그래서 수출을 저희가 많이 하려고 하고 있죠
이쯤에서 약간 김 만드는 기업의 어떤 숫자도 궁금한데 볼만한 숫자가 있을까요?
어 김 만드는 회사는 주로 이제 수출 관점에서 보면은 이제 CJ인
이나 동원 대상이 대기업이 이제 주인긴 한데요 사실은 중견기업들도 요즘 잘 나가는 회사 많습니다
예를 들어서 이제 광천김 2024년에 매출이 2,200억에 영업이익 144억을 했어요 꽤 잘 나가구요 성경김은 많이 들어보셨죠?
아 성경김 그 속도로에서 자주 보여요 그쵸 성경김 같은 경우 매출액 1,230억에 영업이익 83억 근데 이제 25년 12월인가 얼마 불과 몇 달 전에 삼천리그룹에
1,200억에 팔렸거든요 이 정도면 영업이익 대비 한 15배 나오는 거잖아요?
미래를 봤다 왜냐면 내수 어떤 이 식료품 소비재 기업한테 10배 이상을 주는 경우가 잘 없어요
요즘엔 이제 10배 이상이 넘어갈 정도로 요즘 이제 김 회사들에 대한 이 사모펀드들의 관심이 되게 높습니다
약간 예상되는 성장성이 아주 높은 평가를 받고 있는
왜냐면 이제 김은 자꾸 수출로 뚜껑이 열리고 있으니까 어 그래서 계속 이제 잘 나가고 있구요
만전김 우리 남양주의 자존심 남양주의 공장에 있습니다 만전김 매출액 800억에 영업이익 96억 여기는 약간 고급김으로 포지셔닝을 잘 돼있고
여기가 제일 비싸요 비싼 김이에요 백화점에 납품한 만전김 영업이익률도 다른 데보다 높고 대천김도 매출액 1,300억에 영업이익 한 100억으로
잘나가는 기업들은 대충 1,000억원대 2,000억원대 매출액에 한 100억원대의 영업이익을 기록할 정도로 꽤 수준급으로 잘 나가는 회사들이 꽤 많습니다
김은 아직 갈 길이 멉니다 제가 봤을 때는 김은 품질관리부터 시작해서 등급이라든가 이런 것도 체계들을 잡아줘야 되는데 아직 한국엔 체계가 없어요
등급이 없어요 그래서 우리가 비싼 좋은 김을 먹고 싶다 라고 생각하면 비싼 걸 사야 되는데 그 또한 품질과 가격이 막 완벽하게 비례하진 않아요
그러니까 이 고급시장을 열어주려면
제도적으로 뭐가 1급이고 뭐가 A급이고 이런 것들을 사실을 만들어야되는 제도적 정비가 필요한 시기인거죠
이제 막 시작하는 그런 카테고리라고 그러게 올라갈 수도 있을 것 같다는 생각이 드는데요 맞아요 시장에서 내가 좋은 김을 먹고 싶다고 했을 때
서치를 할 수가 없어요 그냥 가격으로만 볼 뿐이지 가격도 애매해요 가격이 다 비슷한 저가고 해봤자 올리브유 들기름 참기름 막
뭘 발랐냐 뭘 번거웠냐 이런거지 원초에 대한 경쟁력이라든가 원초에 대한 등급 자체가 아직 한국은 그게 미비해서
여기서 표준을 잡는 회사가 농심이나 오리온이 될 수도 있겠다
투자할 데가 없는데 여기 큰일났네 다 비상장이여 가지고 그래서 지금 사모펀드들이 냄새를 맡고 지금 쌀 때 갈 것 같은데
약간 이래서 다들 이제 매수하려고 하시는 거 같아요 너무 적가요 결론적으로 저희가 지금까지 본 이런 기업들 중에서 미래에 어떤 K푸드 K스낵
부분에서 좀 떠오를 만한 기업 강자가 될 기업은 좀 어디라고 보시나요 롯데 잘할 수 있다
롯데 화이팅!
너무 늦게 얘기하셨어
초콜렛이 된다
저는 진짜 김 회사가 지금 파는 것도 다 종류가 많지 않잖아요 김을 스낵으로 여기기 시작한 게 이제 막 시작됐으니까 누가 김으로 맛있는 베리에이션을 하느냐
약간 이게 관건일 수도 있을 것 같아요
그쵸 그쵸 저는 이제 그래도 스낵이 저력이 있을 거라고 생각해요 이미 40년 50년 60년 하면서 나름 이 재료 가공이나 맛을 표현하는 것에 있어서 노하우가 굉장히 많이 쌓인 기업들이거든 다
우리나라에서
우리나라 회사들이 그러다 보니까 농심 같은 경우는 라면으로 지금 전세계 깔아놨거든요 어느 정도 이제 유통의 힘도 있고 하다 보니까 농심 쪽에서 뭔가 한번 불닭 모먼트가 있으면 주가가 확 오를 수도 있겠는데 라는 생각은 살짝 드네요
그럴 수 있겠네요 한국 과자가 그 해산물 파우더 아까 새우깡 자갈치 그러니까 이런 류가 되게 특이해요
어 그쵸 해물을 과자에 넣어서 먹는다는 거죠
그리고 또 워낙 유명한 또 연예인들이 많으니까
그것도 무시할 수는 없죠 사실은
케이푸드가 그렇게 잘 된 게 사실은 그런 넷플릭스라든가 유튜브라든가 케이팝이랑 같이 간 거잖아요
그러면 이 시장도 훨씬 잠재력은 클 수도 있네요
자 이번 주 비주류 경제학에서는 정동현 팀장님과 함께 과자 이야기를 나눠봤는데요 마무리 질문 던져보려고요
팀장님에게 식음료 산업이란
제가 사회 시작했을 때부터 봤던 일을 했던 사업 전 유통으로 일을 했지만 그러니까 이게 맞으면 많이 안 나와요
근데 일해야 될 사람이 되게 많아요
어 어 어
많은 사람들이
이게 첨단 산업이긴 하지만 말단에서 유통과 이런 것들에 대한 인력 투자라든가
사실 우리의 쌓인 추억도 되게 많은 사업이에요
그래서 저는 사실 애정이 되게 많고 한국 과자를 밖에서 봤을 때 해외에서 봤을 때 더 반가운 것처럼
앞으로 좀 더 잘 됐으면 좋겠고 그다음에 계속 얘기를 나눠보면 나눠볼수록 아 잠재력이 분명히 있다
전 그런 생각이 듭니다
그 뒤에 이제 있는 사람들의 이야기 같은 것들이 있는 그런 산업이네요
네
감사합니다
고맙습니다